you know
some of you who for instance
I don't know Sonia Krishna
Shoshana some of you I could count on
being here every time some of you show
up once in a while those of you who show
up once a while happened to be very
lucky if you pick today because what
we're going to do today is I'm going to
tell you stuff that might make a big
difference in your whole life because
I'm going to tell you how you can make
yourself smarter no kidding and I'm also
going to tell you how you can package
your ideas so that you'll be the one
that's picked instead of some other slug
so that's what we're going to do today
so it's it's a it's the it's the most
important lecture of the semester the
sleep lecture is only the second most
important this is the most important now
the vehicle is going to get us there is
a discussion about how it's possible to
learn in a way that is a little
reminiscent of what we talked about last
time because last time we learned
something very definite from a small
number of examples this takes it one
step further and shows how it's possible
to learn in a human-like way from a
single example in one shot so it's
extremely different very different from
everything you've seen before everything
that involves learning from thousands of
trials and gazillions of examples and
only when it's a little tiny bit if
anything from each of them this is going
to learn something definite from every
example so here's a here's that here's
the classroom example what's this it's
an arch I know the architects are
complaining that it's not an arch in
architecture land it's a post and lintel
construction but for us today it's going
to be an arch now if you were from Mars
and didn't know what an arch was I might
present this to you and you would get a
general idea of some things that might
be factors but you'd have no idea what's
really important so then I would say
that's not an arch and you will learn
something very definite from that
and then I would shove these together
and put this back on and I would say
that's not an arch either and you learn
something very definite from that and
then I could paint the top one blue and
you learn something very definite from
that and how how do how can that happen
is the question how can that happen in
detail and what might it mean for human
learning and how you can make yourself
smarter that's what that's where we're
going to go all right so how can we make
a program that's as smart as a Martian
about learning things like that well if
you were writing that program surely the
first thing you would do is you would
try to get off the picture as quickly as
possible and into a symbol land where
things are clearer about what the
important parts are so you'd be
presented with a with an initial example
that might look like this I will call
that an example but it's more than just
an example it's the initial model that's
the starting point and now we're going
to couple that with something that's not
actually an arch but looks a whole lot
like one at least on it on the
descriptive level to which we're about
to go so here's something that's not an
arch but its description doesn't differ
from that of an arch very much in fact
if we were to draw this out in a kind of
network we would have a description that
looks like this and these relations
would be support relations and this
would be drawn out like so and the only
difference would be this Oh
the only difference would be that those
support relations that we had in the
initial model the the example have
disappeared down here in this in this
configuration but since it's not very
different from the model we're going to
call this a near-miss
and now you see we've abstracted away
from all the details that don't matter
to us last time we talked about a good
representation having certain qualities
qualities like making the right things
explicit well this makes the structure
explicit and it suppresses information
about blemishes on the surface we don't
care much about how tall the objects are
we don't we don't think it matters what
they're made of so this is a
representation that satisfies the first
of the criteria from last time it makes
the right things explicit and by making
the right things explicit it's it's
exposing from some constraint here with
respect to what it takes to be an arch
and we see that if those support
relations are missing it's not an arch
so we ought to be able to learn
something from that what we're going to
do is we're going to put these two
things together we're going to describe
the difference between the two we're
going to reach the conclusion that says
there's only one difference one kind of
difference with two manifestations two
disappearing support relations we're
going to conclude that those support
relations are important we're going to
term we're going to term red because
they're so important and we're going to
change the name from support to must
support so this is a this is our new
model this is an evolving model that now
is decorated with information about
what's important so if you're going to
match something against this model it
must be the case that those support
relations are there if it's not there if
they're not there it's not an arch all
right so we've learned something
definite from a single example this is
not 10,000 trials this is teacher
presenting something to the student and
the student learning something
immediately in one step about what is
some what's important in an arch so
let's do it again that was so much fun
let's do this one
same as before except that now when we
describe this thing there are some
additional relations these relations and
those are touch relations so now when we
compare that is that an arch no that's a
near-miss when we compare that near-miss
with our evolving model we see
immediately once again there's exactly
one difference two manifestations the
touch relations so we can immediately
conclude that these touch relations are
interfering with our belief that this
could be an arch so what do we do with
that we put those together again and we
build ourselves a new model it's much
like the old model that still has the
imperatives up here we have to have the
support relations but now down here let
me draw a knot science through there
this these are must not touch relations
so now you can't match against that
model if those two side supports are
touching each other so just two steps
we've learned two important things about
what what has to be in place in order
for this thing to be considered to be an
art so our Martian is making great
progress but our Martian isn't through
because there's some more things we
might want it to know about the nature
of arches for example they might present
it for this one
oh that looks just like our initial
example it's an example just like our
initial example but this time the top
has been painted red but I'm still
saying that that's an arch so once again
there's only one difference and that
difference is that in the description of
this object we have the additional
information that the color on the top is
red
and we've been carrying along without
saying so that the color of the top and
the evolving model is white so now we
know that the top doesn't have to be
white it can be their red or white
so we'll put those two together and
we'll get a new model and that new model
this time once again will have three
parts it will have the relations in a
parotid form that we've been carrying
along now the must support and the must
not touch but now we're going to turn
that color relation itself into an
imperative and we're going to say the
top has to be either red or white so now
once again in one step we learn
something definite about archness two
more steps suppose now we present it
with this example that's an example and
this time there's going to be a little
paint added here as well this time we're
going to have the top painted blue likes
it like so and so the description will
be like so and now we have to somehow
put that together with our evolving
model to make a new model there's some
choices here and our choice depends
somewhat on the nature of the world that
we're working in so suppose we're
working in flag world there are only
three colors red white and blue now
we've seen them all if we've seen them
all then what we're going to do is we're
going to say that the evolving model now
is adjusted yet again like so oh those
are imperative still let me carry that
along
at this time this guy the color relation
goes out here too anything at all
so we could have just not drawn it at
all but then we would have lost track to
the fact that we've actually learned
that anything can be there so we're
going to retain the relation but have it
point to the anything-goes marker well
we're making great progress and I said
there's just one more thing to go so let
me let me compress that into this area
here what I'm going to add this time is
I'm going to say that the example is
like everything you've seen before
except at the top there's now one of
those kinds of child's bricks so you
have a choice actually about whether
this is an arch or not but if I say yeah
it's still an arch then we add a little
something to its description so it's
description would look like this
same things that we've seen before in
terms of support but now would have a
relation that says that this top is a
wedge and over here something we've been
hearing along but not writing down this
top is a block a brick I guess in the
language of the day so if we say that it
can be either a wedge or a brick on top
what do we do with that once again it
depends on the nature of representation
but if we say that we have a
representation that has a hierarchy of
parts so bricks and wedges are both
children's blocks and children's box or
toys then we can think of drawing in a
little bit of that hierarchy right here
and saying well let's see immediately
above that we've got big brick or wedge
and a little bit above that we've got
block and a little bit above that we've
got toy and a little bit above that we
eventually get to any physical object so
what does it do in response to that kind
of situation you have the choice but
what the program I'm speaking of
actually did was to make a conservative
generalization up here just to say that
it's one of those guys so once again
it's learn something definite let me see
let me count the steps 1 2 3 4 5 and
it's learned four things so the
generalization of the color it took two
steps to get all the way up to delt care
so note how that contrasts with anything
you've seen in a neural net or anything
you will see downstream and some of the
other learning techniques that we'll be
talking about that involve using
thousands of samples to learn what it is
to learn whatever it is that is intended
to be learned let me show you another
example of how these heuristics can be
put to work
so there are two sets of drawings we
have the upper set and the lower set and
your task you smart humans working in
vast parallelism your task is to give me
a description of the top trains that
distinguishes and separates them from
the trains on the bottom
we got it
nobody's got it well let me try one on
you the top trains all have a short car
with a closed top so how is it possible
that a computer could have figured that
out now it turns out that it figured it
out with much the same apparatus that
I've shown you here in connection with
the arches just deployed in a somewhat
different manner in this particular case
the examples are presented one of the
time by a teacher who's eager for the
student to learn in this case the
examples are presented all at once and
the machine is expected to figure out a
description that separates the two the
two the two groups and here's how it
works what you do
as you start with one of them but you
have a lot of them you have some
examples we'll call the examples on top
of the plus examples and the examples on
the bottom of the negative examples so
the first thing that you do is you pick
one of the positive examples to work
with anybody get any good guesses about
what we're going to call up yeah you do
we're going to call that the seed it's
just it's just highly reminiscent of
what we did last time when we were doing
phonology but now at a much different
level we're going to pick one of those
guys to be deceide and then we're going
to take these heuristics and we're going
to search for one that loosens this
description so that it covers more of
the positives you see if you have a C
that is exactly a description of a
particular thing and you insist that
everything be just like that that
nothing will match except itself but you
can use these review ristic stew expand
the coverage of the description to
loosen it so that it covers more of the
positives so in your first step you
might cover for example that group of
objects too bad for your side you've
also in that particular case included a
negative example in your description but
perhaps in this next step beyond that
you will get to the point where you've
eliminated all of those negative
examples and zeroed in on all the
positive examples so how might a program
be constructed that would do that sort
of thing well think about the choices
the first choice that you have is to
pick a positive example to be the seed
and once you've picked a particularly
the seed then you can apply your ristic
some of them that you have to make a new
description that may cover the data
better may have more than positives and
fewer the negatives than your in your
previous step but this if you have a lot
of heuristics and these are a lot of
heuristics because there's a lot of
description
that set of trains there are lots of
possible things you could do with those
heuristics because you could apply them
anywhere so this tree is extremely large
so what do you do to keep it under
control well you know now you now you
have answers to questions like that by
knee-jerk right the branching factor is
too big you want to keep a few solutions
going you have some way of measuring how
well you're doing so you can use a beam
search this piece here was originally
worked out by a friend of mine now alas
to see Swiss chard mill Kowski one is at
the University of Illinois of course he
wasn't interested in toy trains he was
interested in soybean diseases and so
this exact program was used to build
descriptions of soybean diseases it
turned out to be better than plant
pathology books but you know we now have
two ways of deploying the same
heuristics like my vocabulary is is in
need of enrichment because I'm talking
about those heuristics and one of the
nice things that Mill Kowski did for me
a long time ago is give each of them a
name so here are the names that work
that were developed by Mackowski what's
happening here you're going from an
original model to understand some things
are essential so he called this they
require a linker istic and here in the
next step we're forbidding some things
from being there so Mackowski called
that you ristic the forbid linker istic
and in the next step we're saying it can
be either red or white so we have a set
of colors and we're extending it and
over here in this heuristic going from
red or white anything goes that's
essentially forgetting about color
altogether so we'll cronic going to call
that drop link
even though for reasons of keeping track
we don't actually get rid of it we just
have to have it pointing to the anything
marker and finally in this last step
what we're doing with this tree of
categories is we're climbing up it one
step so we call that the climb tree
heuristic so now we have the vocabulary
of things we can do in the learning
process and having that vocabulary gives
us power over it right because those are
names we can now say oh well what's new
here is the drop leg heuristic or what
you need over there is the extend cetera
state so now I want to back up and yet
it yet another time and say well let's
see what we were working with that
phonology stuff all I did was generalize
are we just generalizing here no we're
both generalizing and specializing so
when I say that the links over here that
are developed in our first step are
essential this is a specialization step
and when I say they can't be they cannot
be touch relations that's a
specialization step because we're able
to match fewer and fewer things when we
say you can't have touch relations but
over here when I go here and say well it
doesn't have to be white it can also be
red that's a generalization now we can
match more things and when I drop the
link altogether that's a generalization
and when I climb the tree that's a
generalization and that's why when I
- this notional picture of what happens
when the housekeeper program does it
research to find a solution to the train
problem
they're both specialization steps which
draw in the number of things that can be
matched and generalization steps that
make it broader so let's see we've also
got the notion of near-miss and we've
got the notion of example some of these
things are examples some are near misses
we've got generalization specialization
does one can go with one or the other or
are they all mixed up in a relationship
to each other can you generalize and
specialize with near misses what do you
think you think we don't think soluble
what do you think the mirror to see you
leave position let's see if that's right
so we got specialization here and that's
a near miss
we've got specialization here and that's
a near miss we've got generalization
here and that's an example we've got
generalization here and that's an
example and we've got generalization
here and that's an example so he balls
got that one nail the example is always
generalized and this near misses always
specialized so we've got apparatus in
place allow us to both expand what we
could match eed shrink what we can match
so what does it's got to do with
anything well which one these methods is
better by the way this one this one
requires a teacher to organise
everything up this one can handle it in
batch mode this one is the sort of thing
you would need to do with the human
because we don't have much memory that
would is the sort of thing that a
computer is good at because it has lots
of memory so which one's better well it
depends on what you're trying to do if
you're trying to build a machine that
analyzed the stock market you might want
to go that way or soybean diseases or
any one of a variety of practical
problems trying to model people then
maybe this is a way that deserves
additional merit how do you get all that
sorted out well one way to get it all
sorted out is to talk in terms of what
are call sometimes called Felicity
conditions
so when I talk about felicity conditions
I'm talking about a teacher and a
student and covenants that hold between
them so here's the teacher that's B and
here's the student that's you and the
objective of interaction is to transform
an initial state of knowledge into a new
state of knowledge so that the student
is smarter and able to make use of that
new knowledge to do things it couldn't
be done before by the student so the
student over here has a learner and he
has something that uses what is learned
and the teacher over here has a style so
if any learning is to take place one
side has to know something about the
other side for example it's helpful if
the teacher understands the initial
state of the student and here's one way
of thinking about that
you can think of what you know is
forming a kind of network so initially
you don't know anything but as you learn
you start developing quanta of knowledge
and these quanta of knowledge are all
linked together by prerequisite
relationships that might indicate how
you get from one quantum to another so
maybe you have generalization links
maybe you have specialization links
maybe you have combination links but you
can think of what you know as forming
this kind of network now your state of
knowledge in any particular time can
then be viewed as a kind of wavefront in
that space so if I the teacher know
where your wavefront is can I do a
better job of teaching you stuff sure
for this reason suppose you make a
mistake m1 that depends on q1 way way
behind your wavefront what do I do if I
know that you made a mistake of that
kind oh I just say oh you forgot that
you need a semicolon after that kind of
statement I just remind you of something
you certainly know you just overlooked
right the other hand suppose you make a
mistake that depends on a piece of
knowledge way out here that kind of
mistake m2 what do I say to you that or
you think okay what do you think I know
that's not that's not
I would say something like that all
right
suggested saying oh don't worry about
that we'll get to it we're not ready for
it yet so in this case I remind somebody
of something they already know in this
case I tell them they'll learn about it
later so what do I do is mistake number
three that's the learning moment that's
where I can push the wavefront out
because everything is in place to learn
this stuff at the next radius so if I
know that the student has made a mistake
on that wavefront that's when I say this
is the teaching moment this is when I
explain something so that's why it's
important for the teacher to have a good
model where the student is in the
initial state of knowledge next thing
that's important to know for the teacher
to know is the way that the T student
learns because if the student is a
computer that can handle this stuff in
batch that's one thing if the student is
a 3rd grader who has a limited capacity
to store stuff then that makes a
difference in how you teach it you might
teach it that way to the 3rd grader and
that way buried underneath this board to
a computer so you need to understand the
way that they learn the computational
capacity of the learner and there's also
a need to understand the computational
capacity of the user box down there
because sometimes you can be taught
stuff that you can't actually use so by
now most of you have attempted to read
that sentence up there right and it
seems screwy right
it seems unintelligible perhaps it's a
garden path sentence it makes perfectly
it's perfectly good English but the way
you generally read it it doesn't because
you have a limited buffer in your
language processor what does this mean
you're expecting this to be to question
but it's actually a command here's the
deal
somebody's got to give the students
their
raise well we can have their parents do
it have the braids given to their
students by their parents then
so it's command and you garden path on
it because you have limited buffer space
in your language processor so with
parentheses you can understand it you
could learn about it you can see that
it's good English but you can't
generally process that kind of sentence
without going back and starting over and
what about going the other way
are there covenants that we have to have
here that involve the student
understanding some things about the
teacher well the first thing there is is
trust the student has to presume that
the teacher is teaching the student
correct information not lying to the
student gratify the earl here because
presumably you all think that I'm not
trying to screw by telling you stuff
that's a lie there's also this sort of
thing down here an understanding of the
teachers style so you might say well
Professor X all he does is read slice to
us in class oh why go you wouldn't be
entirely mis-advice that's an
understanding one kind of style or you
could say well Oh Winston he tries to
tell us something definite and convey a
family of powerful ideas in every class
I maybe it's worth dragging yourself out
of bed at ten o'clock in the morning
those are style issues and those are
things that the student uses to
determine how to match student style
against that of the of the instructor so
that helps us to interpret or think
about differences in style so that we
can appreciate whether we ought to be
learning that way where that way is the
way that's underneath down here the the
way you would teach a computer the way
no Kowski taught a computer about
soybean diseases they can do it that way
or we can do it this way with a teacher
who deliberately organizes and shapes
the learning sequences sequence for the
benefit of a student who has a limb
and processing capability now your
healings right so think about what the
machine has to do here the machine in
order to learn anything and definite in
each of those steps the machine has to
build the description so it has to
describe the examples to itself that's
unquestioned right because what it's
doing is looking at the differences so
it can't look at the differences unless
it's got descriptions of things so if
you're like the machine then you can't
learn anything unless you build
descriptions unless you talk to yourself
and if you talk to yourself you're
building the kind of descriptions that
make it possible for you to do the
learning and you say to me I'm an MIT
student I want to see the numbers so let
me show you the numbers and what I want
to show you numbers today and what the
numbers I'm going to show you show you
the virtues of talking to yourself so
here's the experiment experiment is done
by a friend of mine Michelle and she
always seems to go by the name Miki Chi
Oh
various so here's the deal the students
so that she worked with were expected to
learn about elementary physics 801 type
stuff and she took eight subjects and
she had them she took them through a
bunch of examples and then she gave them
an examination so eight subjects and so
they divided into two groups the bottom
half and the top half the ones which the
ones who did better than average and the
ones that did worse than average so then
you can say well okay what does that
mean you can say how much did they talk
to themselves well that was measured by
having them talk out loud as they solve
the problems on an examination so we can
ask how much self explanation was done
by the smart ones versus the less smart
ones and here are the results the worst
ones the worst for said about 10 things
to themself the best for said 35 things
to themselves that's pretty dramatic
difference here here's the data in a
straightforward form this by the way
points out that the smart ones scored
twice as high as the less smart ones and
when we look at the number of
explanations they gave themselves in two
categories the smart ones said three
times as much stuff to themselves as the
less smart ones so as you can see the
explanations break down into two groups
some have to do with monitoring and not
with physics at all there are things
like oh hell I'm stuck or I don't know
what to do
and the others do with physics like the
things like well maybe I should draw a
force diagram or let me write down F
equals MA or something like that as
physics knowledge I think it's
interesting that they
the average scores differed by a factor
of two and the average talking to
oneself differed by a factor of three
now this isn't quite there because
what's not clear is if you encourage
somebody to talk to themself and they
talk to themselves more than they would
have ordinarily does that make them
score better all we know is that the
ones who talk to themselves more do
score better but anecdotally talking to
some veterans in 6:03 for they've
started talking to themselves more when
they solve problems and they think that
it makes them smarter now I would
caution you not to do this too much in
public because that people get the wrong
idea if you talk to yourself too much
but it does seem that does it does in
fact seem seem to help now what I did
last time as I told you how to be a good
scientist let me tell you now is how to
make yourself smarter and I want to
conclude this hour by telling you about
how you can package your ideas so they
have greater impact so I guess I I could
have said how to make yourself more
famous but I've limited myself to saying
how to package your ideas better and the
reason you want to package your ideas
better is because if you package your
ideas better than the next slug then
you're going to get the faculty position
in they're not they say to me I'm going
to be an entrepreneur the same thing
you're going to get the venture
capitalist money in the next slug won't
if you package your ideas better so this
little piece of work on the arch
business got a whole lot more famous
than I ever expected I did it when I was
young and stupid and didn't have any
idea of what qualities might emerge from
a piece of work that would make it well
known I only figured it out much later
but in retrospect it has five qualities
that you can think about when you're
deciding whether you're packaging of
your idea is in a form that will lead to
that idea becoming well-known and since
there are five of them
it's convenient to put them all on the
points of a star like so so quality
number one I've made these all into s
words just to make them easier to
remember quality number one is that
there's some kind of symbol associated
with the work some kind of visual handle
that people will use to remember your
idea so what's the visual symbol here
well that's astonishingly easy to figure
out right that's the arch for years
without my attending it this was called
arch learning so you need a symbol then
you also need a slogan that's a kind of
verbal handle it doesn't explain the
idea but it serves an but it's enough of
a handle to as Minsky would say put you
back in the mental state you were in
when you understood the idea in the
first place so what is the slogan for
this work anybody have any ideas pretty
obvious what's that what's that what's
process work you don't look for that
example if there's symmetry there it
posits the model is a lot of those since
in there this next thing you need if
your work is going to become well-known
as a surprise
what's the surprise with this stuff well
the surprise everything that had been
done in artificial intelligence having
to do learning before this time was
precursors to neural nets thousands of
examples to learn anything so the big
surprise was that it was possible for a
machine to learn something definite from
each of the examples so that note now
goes by the name of one-shot learning
that was the surprise that a computer
could learn something definite from a
single example so let's see rumbles that
we've almost completed our star but
they're two more points on so this point
is the salient what's a salient what's a
salient idea Jose do you know what a
salient that is two shots ah-ha did it
work wrong answer very good in that shot
what is it good yes
roasted what somebody's thinking about
not quite
yeah sorry there yeah yeah really clear
we're closer
zero certainly wagons here zeroing in on
it yes that's where it to but if you
study military history what's the
salient on a fort well it's a good word
to have in your vocabulary because it it
so it sort of means all of those things
but what it really means is something
that sticks out so on a fort I mean if
this were a fort these would all be
salient because they stick out so a
salient idea is usually important
because it sticks out but it's not the
meaning is not important meaning it's
stick out so a piece of work becomes
more famous if it has something that
sticks out it's interesting there are
theses that have been written at MIT
that have too many good ideas and how
can you have too many good ideas where
you can have too many good ideas if no
one idea rises above and becomes the
idea that people think about when they
think about you we have people on the
faculty who would have been more famous
if their theses had fewer ideas it's
amazing so this piece of work did have a
salient and the salient idea was that
you could get one shot learning via the
use of near misses that was the salient
idea the fifth thing I talk more about
this in my how to speak lecture in
January the fifth thing I like to people
to try to incorporate into their
presentations is a story
because we humans somehow love stories
we love people that tell us stories we
love things to be packaging stories and
believe me I think all of education is
essentially about storytelling and story
understanding so if you want your idea
to be sold as a venture capitalist if
you want to get that faculty job if you
want to get your book sold to a
publisher if you want to sell something
to a customer ask yourself if your
presentation has these qualities in it
and if it has all of those things it's a
lot more likely to be effective than it
doesn't and you'll end up being famous
now you say to me well being famous that
sounds like the Sloan School type of
concept isn't it immoral to want to be
famous
maybe that's a decision you can make but
whenever I think about the question I I
somehow think of the idea that your
ideas are like your children you want to
be sure that they have the best life
possible and so if they're not packaged
well they won't I'm also reminded of an
evening I spent at a soiree with a Julia
Child Julia and there's me and I have no
idea how come I got to sit next to Julia
Child I think they thought I was one of
the rich Winston's the Winston Flowers
it would Harry Winston diamonds or
something like that ere I was sitting
next to Julia Child and the interesting
thing that way you know said now telling
a story the interesting thing about this
experience was that there's a constant
flow of people happen to be all women
people are going past his child saying
how wonderful she was to have made such
an enormous change in their life must
been ten of them it was amazing just
steady flow so eventually I leaned over
to her and I said this child is it fun
to be famous
and she thought about it a second and
said you get used to it and that had a
profound effect on me because you always
say well what's the opposite like is it
fun to be ignored and the answer is no
it's not much fun to be ignored so yeah
it's a it's something you can get used
to but you can never get used to having
your stuff ignored especially if it's
good stuff so that's why I commend to
you this business about packaging ideas
and now you see that six oh three four
is not just about AI it's about how to
do good science it's how to make
yourself smarter and how to make
yourself more famous
you